Hey yeh we-we-we're back!
Ouh!
What is he doing?
What the hell? (o.o)
'Poods you're lookin' real tasty :Q'
'right now'
God damn it!
I forgot
You're such a jerk
He's being controlled!
He's being mind controlled!
Well I have this!
'Member?
AHHHH!
He's eating me!
WHAT?!
(screams)
Ohhhh...
What?
What the hell?!
I thought we were friends
That's why they're called man-eaters
Was this supposed to happen?
I'm so confused
Jesus...
(footsteps)
(creaking)
What is goin' on here?
They hunted them or something, it looks like
And then controlled them - for war
Was I supposed to die there?
I think I was
Did I just come out of his butthole or something?
Sorry about that one!
Something changed?
What did he react to?
Maybe he remembered what happened
Alright well we'll keep playing The Last Guardian
Oh nooo!
Oh the glowing mirror!
We don't have it anymore
That's what he reacted to
Awwww...
Wake up!
Okay so we don't have the mirror
We don't know how to wake him up
We need to go here and pull this "leever"
Do we gotta yell in his ear or something?
Oh no! Something fell on him
No - no that was just his wing
Okay, uhh
Wake up, buddy
How do I wake him up?
Ohh, his tail
*gasp*
What if I used his tail?
To climb on?
There we go!
Oh my God!
That's soo cool!
Hup!
Wooo!
Oh my god, water
Didn't expect this
Where- uh- where do we go then?
This doesn't really help me
Or does it?
Ohh, what is this?
What - is this underneath the bridge?
That's so cool!
Hey, we're first person now, that's -
I was enjoying the other angle
This is so cool..
Okay
So now we can dip in on the other side
(singing) ~Dippin on the other siiiiiide!~
No
Okay
Here we go
He's so cute - everyone's so cute
Shhhhooo kyut
I want a plushie
I want a Trico plushie
Oh my gahh
That is sooper spooks
Sooper spoosky
armory lon
Ohhh, we got some enemies
I got enemies
No, shut up
Fuck
Which way?
This way?
Let's keep our distance - whaddya say?
Huh?
Not - okay wow
You're loco crazy straight up insane
Dawg
Alright we're makin our way downtown
This music, man
This way?
What are the other option - this way?
Hey - maybe there's some drugs here
No, there's nothing there
Who am I kidding?
Why do I keep lookin' for drugs?
I don't know - seems like a bad idea, you know?
Seems like a "turrible" idea
Man.. Okay
Well. we got something here - it's so pretty!
So pretty
Okay
What is this though?
Where are we now?
Oh we're here!
That's perfect
That works out excellent!
Finally - I was like, I know we have to go here
I just..
Don't know how
(grunts and makes fart noise)
I hope that wakes him up!
Ay Trico
You still sleep-o?
Ehh
Okay, alright, that's fine
No, you're supposed to jump down
(yells)
That's exactly how I wanted to do it
Okay, so
Don't kill me
AHHHHHHH
Fuck
Shiiiit!
Oh no!
Okay, maybe they're scared of light
Ahh, fuck
Don't push me
What the hell? These are creepy as hell!
What the fuck is this?
Oh they're using jitsu!
Ahhh he got me!
Let me go!!!
They're using Ninjutsu
Trico!!
Got 'em!
What the fuck?
Fucken' 'ninyujutsu' shit
I knew I shouldn't have done that.
Trico!
Wake owppp
Trico, Trico
Yaediyo
Come on, I need you!
They're coming
Yaediyo?
Oh, yes, it worked!
Oh my gawwdd
It's out of (?) ... morning schnack
Eat 'em
That's ma boy
Oh my god!
Stop the music
We got more of them
That one has a sword and shit
Oh my god it's fighting Tric- OHHHHHH
DAAAYMMMMM
DAAAYYEEEM
Dude, Trico, that was AWESOME!!
Oh there's more, there's more, shit
I better ow, oh, I'm gonna yo, you gonna kill me you gonna kill me
Jesus christ
He smacks the shit outta me
Oh god he's still crazy
Okay, alright
Dude, I'm fucken - i'm fucken hrarth (?) man
OK Jesus christ OK we better find him some drugs ASAP
Oh we gotta pet him, that's what I was thinking but I didn't think-
Hey buddy-
That worked?
I mean I can't-
There we go
Oh that feels good
You know where to massage me, Poods
Whoa - look at this
We got a- weird footsteps here
So this is where I need to go, huh?
Jesus
What is this?
Is he too fat? He is too fat.
Trico: God damn it, shut up!
Trico: Shut up I'm not too fat!
I mean, I can't help you with instant weight loss you know?
There it is.
Okay, that's cool.
I'll be right there, Tric- Tric- Trico ma man
Oh shit, oh shit, careful, careful
Kerful, kerful, veri kerful
There you go
Very nice
And then we jump
Ooooh look at that!
If Trico saw that he'd be like 'Hell ye'
Dude, that shit was hella tight, yo
Oh shit, shit, shit. Don't wanna fall down now, that'd be a pain in the ass
Focus, focus
Jump!
What the hell did I just do?
Hey look, there's a hole
My favorite thing in the world. (We know, Poods)
How did you know? (We just know)
Oh this is a well?
It's very pretty
Take that. Look at this.
I feel like you can-
You can literally just take a screenshot at any point and it'll look like a great wallpaper, you know?
Look at that, we're out!
But we can't leave our mayn!
He's probably super scared right now.
Tricohh
Oh, this is the cage!
The stupid cage!
Trico!!
Trico: HAAAYYY
Trico: I thought you left without meh
Is that his butt, he backed up-
Trico: Yes I'm backin' up
Trico: You got a problem?
Trico: Where are you I can't see you
Trico: Oooh there you are
Oh I see, excellent.
Come on, Trico
Trico: Alright, here I go!
Trico: You ready for meh?
Trico: Nailed it, AHHH SHEET SHET SHET. SHET. AHH
Trico: Nailed it!
Good job, Trico, you real- you really did it there.
Oh, look at that.
So much space now.
Never mind.
Okay, where, where do we go now?
Where is he going?
Trico: Oh ma gad I haven't been outside for so long!
Whoa, whoa.
Okay, we have some stuff over here.
Trico: Well I- don't look at me, I don't know.
Where is he goin'?
Okay, he's going somewhere.
Whether we like it or not, Jesus Christ.
Oh my god-
Oh, he jumps over.
Coooool.
Okay-
I should get one of these, they seem- they seem like they're handy.
What now?
Oh my god, you're- you're too fat, how many times do I gotta say it?
Jesus Christ, I just saw his butthole.
Trico: Is that- is that drugs?!
Trico: Oh my guhh
Trico: I wanna sniff that
Mysterious aroma. (That's just you, Poods)
Oh it's this thing.
Okay I cou- I could get up here.
Could I climb this?
Okay soooo- there's a hole there.
You really want that shit don't ya?
Trico: Dude, it smells like strawberries
Let's uh, see what we got here first.
Jesus Christ, I am a lot braver in this game than I am in real life. (We know that)
Okay well, looks like I have nothing, great.
Trico: I swear I can fit, I swear it.
Okay, I'm hoping now we can grab this grass.
Oh yes, okay, FINALLY
Wha- I don't - That should've been more obvious to me, I-
I apologize
I ahpologyze
I'm a fucken idiot.
Let's go down in the pot.
Actually, let's just go down on the ladder, if I can-
This sand- okay.
Here we go, that's how you do it.
Everyone, thank you very much I feel very-
-proud that I did that all by myself.
Here we are, now
Oh look at that, there was even this for us.
Who would've thought.
Gotta push it.
You gotta shove.
BAM! OWWWWWW
*weird yelling noise* It worked, now would you stop being a fucken prick?
Trico: Aww, come on maahn
Trico: It smells so nice-
Is he still seriously trying?
Dude.
The smell is gone.
Trico: No.
Trico: No, NOOOHH
Trico: Well now I'm just stuck.
Trico: I'm out, I'm out.
Trico: Did that on purpose.
Trico: What happened?
Now, can we continue please?
Oh, um..
What?
-just happened?
Is he peeing?
Did he just shit himself, what was that sound?
I cuddled him.
And he went to sleep.
Oh my god that's so cute.
I guess he's tired?
We have to yell in his ear to wake up.
Oh hoooh so coooll
I made him fall asleep, I didn't mean to do that.
Trico: I see you!
Trico: I see you smiiiilinnn'
(singing) Up on the floor
Trico: Looks like you need a hand.
Trico: Too bad I don't have hands.
Trico: I can make it, I can make it through. Don't worry 'bout it.
Trico: I ca- I, I'm, I'm thin enough.
Trico: I'm a skinny- I'm a skinny-
Trico: Look, I made it!
Oh, shit.
Okay, where's his tail?
I bet it's dangling real-
Oh there- I knew it was like perfectly placed tail.
It smells.
Trico: What did you say?!
Hey don't worry abuddit, I'm just climbin'
You don't mind this, do you?
There we go, it's perfect.
I want this kid's outfit. That poncho looks very comfortable.
Trico: Ya you're busy climbin' my ass again?
Shut up.
Oh jees, ah- I
There we go.
Nice.
I think we're back.
Jeeeesus!
Oh my god.
WhereOkay, soo..
Where are we now?
Oh my god, what happened?
I think we gotta jump up on him.
He's jumpin'!
OOOOOOOHHHHHHHHHHHHHH (rip headphone users)
JEEZ
LOUISE
u krazy
Oh my god...
Jees, it scares me. It scares me on a real level.
On a real- my god, I'm gonna die, I'm gonna die.
Don't kill me, don't-
*Don't kill me chant intensifies*
Okay, alright.
I'm not- OOOOKAY, alright. I'm alive somehow.
I'm just gonna hold on tight here.
Oh, what, is this?
It's a cool lookin' place.
He doesn't seem to mind.
I'm tryna jump up.
Ow, so smooth.
So 'preddy'.
It's incredible.
Meine Gott, it's sooww prittie.
Vow, you take a littul bath-OHOHOEHOKhhh
Trico: Arwh, it feels sah gooood.
Trico: I haven't had a shower in like months.
Ya, I knew, I knew. Trust me.
Trico: Arwh dude, this is the best. You should try it, Poods.
I'll be right back, okay, someone's gotta do the job here.
So, is that- is Trico like 'the last guardian'? That would make sense.
Or am I the last- oh we need to go up there?
Whoa no, there's another one?
I was literally- I thought I heard another one, that's why I was like, okay.
Why are there two?
Maybe we're the last guardian.
Someone's the last guardian.
I am the- one, the one.
(singing) Don't need a girl to get respect up on this street. (What?)
Sorry. (That's okay Poods)
Okay, oh shit.
Well, well, well, look who's decided to come in?
Trico: That was my cousin, Tina.
What a great name, huh?
Did you come up with that all by yourself?
Oooookay, alright.
Well that's another way to do it, I suppose.
Trico: You can climb on my tail if you'd like.
Alright fine, I'm coming.
This is just- don't climb into the butthole.
Oh god, don't jump now, NOOOO
*attractive noises (fail)*
Why is his tail so fucking long?
Okay, here we go.
Dude look at that, that looks incredible.
Okay sooo, I need to go there?
Just stand still, please.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Ohhh my god, what is happening?
I'm climbing his eye.
There it is, okay, nice.
This looks dark and scary, I like it.
Awwh, Trico, I know we're bros and all-
Trico: POODS DOOON'T LEAVE MEH
Okay, alright.
Someone has separation anxiety but that's okay, that's okay we can work around that.
There'a a bridge.
Let's cross it
See? You can still see me and all..
Ugh!
Oh you just wanted the snack :O
Look at him
He just-
Trico: THAT'S IT
SEE I DON'T GIVE A SHIT
JUST WANT THAT SHNACK :D
COME ON, GIMME THAT SHNACK :D
PLEASE
I'VE BEEN A REALLY GOOD BOY
I SWEAR
I SWEAR, C'MON
GIVE IT TO ME (x4)
Dzz
Dzaa
FUCK *laughs*
OHHH NO XD
Trico: YOU FUCKING ASSHOLE!
That's too funny xD
Hey, man, I tried, okay? I fucking tried
You missed
Jesus Christ that's hilarious
Oh my god
Oh this one is already shattered!
Oh even more so
Fuck, I'm so clumsy, I'm all over the place
Did it!
C'mon, buddy! You can do it!